An example of a distance vector routing protocol is the
routing information protocol or RIP. The first version of RIP
was defined in 1982 where edges had unit cost and
infinity. Where the count to infinity problem was 16. Table
refreshes occur every 30 seconds and when an entry changes,
it sends a copy of that update to all of
it's neighbors except for the one that induced the update.
This rule is sometimes called the split horizon rule. The small
value for infinity ensures that the count to infinity
doesn't take very long and every round has a time
out limit of 180 seconds. Which is basically reached, when
a router hasn't received an update from a next hop
for six 30 second periods. In practice, when a router
or link fails in RIP, things can often take minutes
to stabilize. So because of problems such as slow convergence
and count to infinity, protocol designers, look to, other alternatives.